president trump is set to hold a news
conference in minutes
we'll bring you there live when it
happens the president could address the
political firestorm he ignited this
morning
when he asked if the election date
should be changed
over concerns about mail and voter fraud
and the president tweeting just a few
minutes ago
glad i was able to get the very
dishonest lame stream media to finally
start talking about the risks to our
democracy
from dangerous universal mail-in voting
not absentee voting which i totally
support
he added that americans should know the
results of the election the night of
and not days or weeks later democrats
are furious
calling the president a dictator saying
his comments are meant to be a big
distraction
and barack obama going after trump
during the funeral for congressman
john lewis take a look there are those
in power
who are doing their darndest
to discourage people from voting
by closing polling locations and
targeting minorities
and students with restrictive id laws
and attacking our voting rights with
surgical precision
even undermining the postal service
in the run-up to an election
that's going to be dependent on mail-in
ballots so people don't get sick
all right we'll get to barack obama in a
minute i would admit it was a
mischievous tweet juan
but now that the president has our
attention
let's talk about the universal mail in
the voting i found something very
interesting here
new jersey just had a special election
last month it was
all mail-in everybody did it by mail
and 10 of the ballots were rejected
disqualified for signature issues or
they were late many many reasons so if
you have turnout
in 2020 140 million americans casting
their vote
if 10 of those mail-in ballots
are disqualified that's 14 million
americans are disenfranchised
are you okay with that no i would like
to improve it but that's different than
what the president was talking about
he was suggesting there would be fraud
that there would be corruption
that somehow the election might be
tilted one way or another
by people who are acting in some corrupt
manner jesse
so i think that you know i wouldn't even
have democrats to do that they cheated
in the last election
what look i i don't even want to go
there i think president trump won in
2016
uh and i don't think that i think he
said oh
he would have won the popular vote but
there's no evidence again there's no
evidence of any fraud related to
absentee voting or mail-in voting
in this country but again you know
what's important here and i hope this
might be persuasive to you
if you think about marco rubio ted
cruz mitch mcconnell kevin mccarthy
those people are republicans and today
they all said
this is wrong there should be no delay
in the election
of november 2020. that was what they
said i think they were very clear
so i think this is not the action of a
party this is action of one man
who knows he's losing and is willing to
trash democracy
trash our constitution because he's so
upset
i mean when joe biden predicted this in
april joe biden said you know watch
trump is going to try to delay the
election what was the response oh
biden's threatened conspiracy theories
that's nuts
trump won't go there well trump has gone
there today folks
this is wild no one really believes he's
going to delay the election juan you
just fell for it like usual greg how do
you read these tweets and
if you want to comment on barack obama
at the funeral for lewis
be my guest uh
how dare donald trump undermine the
postal service
how dare he undermine the postal service
who are billions in debt what is it i
don't know how much of debt every year
anyway
uh you got trump still is able to work
the media
four years into this with a tweet it's
just too easy he's like sherry
and and the media is like lamb chop do
you remember that little ventriloquist
with a little lamb chop just makes it
move around with the strings
all right here's the deal i'm against in
general
this kind of talk about election
corruption which is why
uh which is why what the democrats did
with the fraudulent steele dossier was
so damaging to the country
i mean they used a fake paid for foreign
intel
to call 2016 into question and that went
on
for three years four years probably
still going on and people were
outraged when other people said feels
kind of like a coup
well maybe it was kind of like a coup
when you find out
more about the the uh the dossier itself
but so you got to blame it on the dams
you know they
the horse left the barn and it was
carrying pandora's box with it
but again this is what what the real
problem is
any close election will be seen as
stolen because of this because of what
the democrats did
in 2016 we are now in trouble because of
what they did
but you know that if joe wins even by a
hair or a hair
plug trump supporters are
trump supporters are not going to riot
they're not going to riot because a
politics to them isn't personal and they
have stuff to do
they're the ones that own the businesses
they're not the ones who are going to
throw chairs
through the windows of the businesses
but if trump wins by a hair
or more what you will see you'll see
more portland more seattle more
manhattan in fact that's what the media
wants you to think
they want you to think that that this
will be
trouble if trump wins they're
essentially psychologically
extorting you to vote in a different way
yeah they're preparing the groundwork
kennedy
to question the results of the election
and i think the concern is
if you don't know who won the night of
the election and you have a bunch of
ballots sitting in the back room
that have been mailed in there could be
some funny business
as we've seen in other elections that's
the dangerous territory
well you know juan was talking about the
president already being a sore loser
and we had to listen to mrs what
happened
for you know it's going on almost four
years now hillary clinton cannot let go
and she was the woman
who challenged then-candidate trump
during one of the debates to accept the
outcome of elections
because you know our country is based in
a democracy where we
accept when we lose except when she
loses
which is phenomenal whenever there's a
system of voting that only one party is
excited about
that always makes me a little nervous i
do like the idea
that different counties and states can
have their own preferred
form of voting in oregon it's all
mail-in ballot and
you know the president's right absentee
ballots are very critical and there are
a lot of people who
opt in to a mail-in ballot system i
don't trust the federal government if
you think that the pandemic response has
been bad
how do you think they're going to do
with a mass
mail-in federally mandated uh voting
system
this quickly it's going it could be a
disaster so
yeah the democrats telling everybody go
outside and protest but don't go outside
and vote i don't know about you dana
i like the idea you go into the voting
booth you're the only one there with
your ballot
you vote for whoever you want and then
it gets counted there
at the polling station and reported that
night
when you get everybody else involved i
just
i don't have a good feeling about that
you could address that or you could
address barack obama
politicizing as many people are saying
the funeral of john lewis
well on the voting thing i think it's
important to say like yes that's ideal
like being able to go to the voting
booth
that is ideal but that is actually just
i think that one of the things that
would be important for
everyone including the president is to
deal in reality the reality is that
there are going to be many states that
offer up uh mail-in voting
he says like he's trying to make a
distinction about
absentee voting versus mail-in voting
and
it's it is a distinction with a
difference
but what's happening is many states
including florida the republican party
of florida
is so worried that their mail in voting
their absentee voting is so low compared
to the democrats already that they
doctored one of the president's tweets
from a while ago to make it look like
it would be a good thing to do mail-in
voting because the president is very
persuasive to
his um supporters who were being asked
about mail and voting like no thanks no
i don't do mail in voting because it's
fraudulent
and so he's trying to make that
distinction i'm trying to think that
except for maybe the fourth of july did
the president actually
just nail any of the news cycles any day
in the month of july
and i think july 4th might have been a
highlight i think some people thought
that was a low light i'd say it was a
highlight you know with a speech at
mount rushmore
and the pageantry there but the number
one thing on people's minds right now
is the coronavirus they're worried about
their schools they're worried about
their health
and they're worried about the economy
and this issue of the mainland voting it
is way down on their list and he's not
talking
about any of those other things today
maybe he will today at the press
conference
um on president obama whether that was
politicizing yeah
but here's the thing you saw the
reaction the family and friends and the
loved ones
believe that what john lewis would have
wanted is for activism
to continue and i think that president
obama was
answering the mail uh by doing that at
that memorial service today
yeah the audience to eat that up